[PIANO MUSIC PLAYING]
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
regardless of topic,
let's just engage in a dialogue.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It's good?
MALE SPEAKER:
Afternoon, my friends.
Pomnyun Sunim is
no ordinary monk.
He's the winner of
the Magsaysay Award,
which is Asia's
Nobel Peace Prize.
He was one of the
very first people
to organize food aid for
North Korea back in the 1990s.
Yeah, back when
even I was young.
His deep engagement
with North Koreans
have made him one of the world's
top experts on North Korea.
He is a popular zen teacher
and he's a widely respected
international
humanitarian leader.
Venerable Pomnyun
Sunim is the chairman
of the Peace
Foundation in Seoul,
which supports policy
research and analysis aimed
at Korean unification--
peaceful unification--
and humanitarian
issues in North Korea.
He is also a Zen master with
the Seoul-based Jungto Society,
which he originally established
in 1988 to facilitate self
improvement through
volunteerism.
And overall, he's
just a cool dude.
And my friends, please welcome
the Venerable Pomnyun Sunim.
Sunim, thank you so
much for being here.
We're so honored to have you.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Thank you for
inviting me to this event.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And it's
great to see you all today.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: You
must be all busy.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So is it OK
for you to be here and waste
your time like this?
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: They
get paid to sit here.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So they
don't have to do anything.
You still pay them?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
Well, I get paid
to sit with you.
[LAUGHTER]
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I think
I need to thank you
all first here at Google.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because of you,
I derive a lot of benefits.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: I travel
all over the world.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I especially
travel to those areas that are
less travelled.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because you allow
a free use of the Google Maps,
I tend to use it very often.
[LAUGHTER]
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Thank you.
INTERPRETER: But there is
also not so good things.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
I travel often,
I should know my way
around fairly well.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I should
know every nooks and crannies
in Seoul.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if I were
to quit from being a monk,
I would have been made
an excellent taxi driver.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But right now,
my talents are now wasted.
It's useless anymore.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
the GPS actually
knows the roads a
lot better than I do.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So another
matter to thank you about--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --is YouTube.
INTERPRETER: So my dialogues,
engagement with folks,
the video clips of those
are on the YouTube.
And that allows
Koreans communities
across the world to be able
to speak with me vicariously.
And that made it easy for
me to engage with them.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Before,
our engagement
was limited by time and space
and limited to areas like this,
spaces like this.
But now our engagement has been
freed from that limitation.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
this is also free.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So thank
you doubly for that.
MALE SPEAKER: So Sunim,
I am aware that you're
on a world tour.
You are touring, you're
giving 115 lectures
in 115 cities in 115 days.
And Mountain View is
lecture number 79.
And tonight you're
going to Oakland,
and they'll be lecture 80.
Young people like
him, lots of energy.
Not old people like me.
So, my dear friend, your
world tour-- what do you
hope to achieve in doing this?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: There's no specific
thing I'm trying to achieve.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So a lot of people
suffer in their everyday lives.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: To listen to them--
INTERPRETER: --and
to engage with them.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
I feel fulfilled
when I see their
suffering alleviated even
by a small amount.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because they
see me first through YouTube.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And they want
to engage with me directly
in person.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And they also
want to ask questions of me.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
I have been asked
to come visit them many times.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But seeing
how Buddhist monks
should be fairly not
busy, but I'm always busy.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I
didn't have time before,
but this time I
actually made time
in order to travel through
the world and meet with them.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Second,
because I only speak Korean,
until now I was able to
engage with Koreans only.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if
I were to be reborn
in the next lifetime
speaking English,
then I'll be able to engage
with English speakers
and other global
citizens, as well.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I'm actually
practicing for my next lifetime
by doing this world tour.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So it's
an investment, per se.
MALE SPEAKER: You do recognize
when you get reborn, you
sort of forget some English?
He's going, oops.
[LAUGHTER]
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So no one has
proved that yet, so we'll see.
MALE SPEAKER: So you
will get a chance
to ask Sunim some questions.
We will leave plenty of time.
So I only have a few
questions, and then we'll
give you plenty of time.
So Sunim, I have to ask
you about North Korea
because you're one of
the world's top experts
on the topic.
And I'm just going to ask you
a very broad question, which
is, talk about peace
and humanitarian issues
in North Korea today.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So when you
say North Korea, images
of dictatorship, nuclear,
and human rights violations.
Those are the images
that come to your mind.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But we don't often
think that there are actually
20 million people living there.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And they are
suffering as we speak.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: They lack food.
INTERPRETER: They lack medicine.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: They lack water.
INTERPRETER: They lack a
lot of essential goods.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: They
don't have electricity.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: They
don't have anything
to burn for heat during winter.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
we only focus
on the bad actions
perpetrated by the leadership,
we forget about the 20 million
people who suffer under them.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I want to focus
on the 20 million people who
are suffering and think
about their suffering.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
they have the right
to ask for help as
part of the human race.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And that's
what I seek to do.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So many of them,
some of them actually cross
the river into China because
they cannot suffer anymore.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
they are refugees.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Of course
China considers them
as illegal aliens
and repatriates them
to North Korea.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So it's a
little dangerous for you
to actually actively help
North Korean refugees in China.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But they also
have the right to be protected.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And so that's why
I give them support when I can.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And human rights
is also very bad in North Korea.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But
it's very difficult
to find a way to
alleviate, improve
that situation in North Korea.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But we do have
consistent and constant
awareness.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
collect information
about the sufferings and let
the international community
know about them.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
they have the right
to live as human beings.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Not to criticize
the North Korean regime,
but to give North Korean
people the opportunity
to live as human beings.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But this
is not an easy work.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
currently there
is a great tension between
North and South Korea.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So North
Korea is the enemy
from South Korean perspective.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So we ignore
the people's plight,
their diseases,
their lack of food.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
since North Korea's
also at odds with
the United States.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
from my perspective,
the US is not really
keeping in principle
to their humanitarian
principles when
it comes to dealing
with North Korea.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
improvements in human rights
situation and
humanitarian aid, I think,
can only really be improved
once the tension surrounding
the Korean peninsula
can be relaxed a little.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So no
matter how feeble
it might be, I do
my best in order
to aid to the cause of peace
on the Korean peninsula.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: To go to peace.
INTERPRETER: The first step
in the road to peace is first,
you have to acknowledge the
difference between you and me.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And second,
try to understand
that the other might act
that way for a reason.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But today,
just because others do not
think the way we do--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --we actually
paint them into a corner,
saying label them as
beast, as Satan, as evil.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But if
you listen to them,
they also think similarly about
South Korea and the United
States.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why it's
difficult, the road to peace.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's
well first we
have to lay the foundation
of mutual understanding
and acknowledgement of
each other's differences
in order to arrive
at lasting peace.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But that path is
strewn with misunderstandings.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if
you claim that we
need to acknowledge
our differences,
understand their
point of view, people
say you are trying
to sympathize.
You are trying to
take their side.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I
try to do what's best
and what's good to
me in my thoughts,
but I get criticized
from both sides.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So perhaps that's
why I live such a long life.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: So Sunim, are
you hopeful about world peace?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: I think it's
going to take some time.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
even just a century ago--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So we usually
lived our lives in the community
that we are born in.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: With
the same ethnicity.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: With
the same religion.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: With
the same culture.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So that
led us to thinking
that we are always right.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But now
we are all intermixed.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And you
have that tension.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So it
takes some time for us
to develop the capacity
to understand each other,
acknowledge each
other's differences.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: I think
we are improving.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So after
a century or so--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --I believe that
we can live together in harmony
on the basis of acknowledgment
of each other's differences
and understanding
of the differences.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It's
not anything else
that becomes a
source of conflict.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So the
differences will actually
be appreciated for bringing
about enrichment to our lives,
rather than being a
source of conflict.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
for example, there
are different flowers
within the same pot.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Different shapes.
INTERPRETER: Different colors.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Different sizes.
INTERPRETER: But see, they
come together to create beauty.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So that's the
world that I'm dreaming about.
MALE SPEAKER: So
is there anything
that Googlers and Google can
help you or help world peace?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So it's important
for Google, as a corporation,
to abide by its fiduciaries to
pursue profit at the same time.
For example, allowing all of
us to use Google Maps for free.
If you could allow us a lot
of spaces, a lot of areas,
a lot of functions that we
could also use in common,
I think that's a
great contribution.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Does that mean
that you won't get paid?
[LAUGHTER]
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So there's
a traditional saying
that if you create a
lot of good blessings,
then you will get the
blessings in return.
I think you are actually
investing a lot of blessing
for your own fortune
in the future.
MALE SPEAKER: Now, don't
be shy to ask any time.
I have one more question
before I open the floor.
So this time I'm going
to shift the focus
to something more local.
Which is, so the
problem with modern life
in a modern society, especially
in the Silicon Valley,
is that people feel
overwhelmed all the time.
So do you have
any advice for how
to address the feeling of
being overwhelmed all the time?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: I'm
not sure, actually.
[LAUGHTER]
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because everything
is becoming faster and faster.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So there's a
saying in Buddhist sacred text.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Say for example,
a rabbit was taking a nap,
then it was alerted, woke up.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It almost felt
like the sky was falling
and the earth was shaking.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
it started running.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
on the [INAUDIBLE]
a deer was asking the rabbit,
where are you running?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And the rabbit
said, the sky's falling.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And the
deer asked, really?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And so the
deer followed the rabbit.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So you know, the
deer wasn't convinced at first,
but he started
following the rabbit.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And other deers.
INTERPRETER: So all the
animals in the forest,
you know, they actually competed
each other, raced each other.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: One might
be ahead of each other,
but they traded places.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
everybody thought
they needed to run away as
soon as possible, as quickly
as possible to live.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But a tall
cliff was waiting for them
at the edge of the forest.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: No one knew about
the existence of the cliff.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So they say, a lion
is watching this from above,
and roared.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So all the
animals were frightened
and they stopped.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So he asked the
cow, where are you going?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And the
cow said, I don't know.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Why
were you running?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
the horse was running.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: To the horse,
why are you running?
He said he didn't know, either.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Why
were you running?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
the sheep was running.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So he
asked all the animals.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: He found the
original runner, the rabbit.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: He said, why did
you run in the first place?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because I
saw the sky was falling
and the Earth shaking.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: He said,
did you really see it?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So let's go back to
that place where you saw this.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: They
go back to the place
where the rabbit
was having a nap.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So he was
sleeping under an acorn tree.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So when an
acorn fell next to him
while he was taking a nap,
that's what frightened him.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So they said this
was a happening, of sorts.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So perhaps that
explains where we are today.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So we are always
racing, but where are we going?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I want to ask
you back the same question.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: The
reason for you to run.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Is it because
of the money you get paid?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Is it
because you have
to contribute to growing Google?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Is it really?
INTERPRETER: Why do you
have to run so fast?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: I think it's time
for us to kind of review that.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And to
tell you this first--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And one more--
INTERPRETER: It is greed that
actually leads to anxiety.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Just because
you want to run fast
doesn't necessarily
mean you run fast.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But we
always want to run fast.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But our
bodies do not agree.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why
it's so tough on us.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why
it's important for us
to kind of stabilize our mind.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER:
Instead of being too
obsessed over
wanting to run fast.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And start
thinking, growing the capacity
to run fast.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But you
know, in modern world,
we usually want
to run fast first.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's
why we feel anxious.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
we feel nervous.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And we
always are worried
that somebody else
is running faster.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And I
think type of anxiety
we are fully capable
of overcoming.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I just wanted
to speak to you about that.
MALE SPEAKER: So the moral of
the story is steel the mind
and never trust
a talking rabbit.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, questions from the audience.
There's on there.
There's one over here.
This lady.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
One of my favorite
modern philosophers
said that the three most
dangerous human addictions
today are heroin, carbohydrates,
and a monthly salary.
His name is Nassim Taleb.
He's Doctor Doom.
So my question to you is most
of us here have at least two
out of those three addictions,
definitely the monthly salary.
And every day I ask
myself the question
of what is the
purpose of humans?
So as a human, what
should be a noble purpose
that should pursue?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Do we
need to have a purpose?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Do
you think that you
need a purpose in your life?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Does a
squirrel have a purpose?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Do
deers in the hills,
do they have a purpose
in their lives?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: They just live.
INTERPRETER: So human beings
are not that different.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So meanings,
or sense of purpose,
is an artifact
created by our mind.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So basically you
create the sense of purpose
that you created,
and then you are
imprisoned by the
sense of purpose.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So you
need to actually gain
an insight into that.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So you have to be
able to look into your mind.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
even though you might not
have a specific purpose--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --if you just
start living out your days--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --while
you are living--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --how do you live?
INTERPRETER: If you
observe people--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: They live in
the midst of suffering.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: They live in the
midst of anxiety, nervousness.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: They
live under stress.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But
then there are those
who actually live freer and
happier than the rest of us.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So a lot
of people think this--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That if
you have a lot of money,
you'll be freer and happier.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: If you
have a high status,
you'll be more free and happier.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It
almost looks that way.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But then is
people with a lot of money
and high position, are they
really freer and happier?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I don't
know how many people you've
encountered in your life so far.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But I have
met a lot of those people.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But they
don't seem so happy.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: They
don't seem so free.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: In a way, they
are even more chased by things.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So what do
we have to do in order
to be more authentically
happy and free?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So the
answers to those questions
we can always explore.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if you look
at how our minds operate--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: For example--
INTERPRETER: --say
this is the stage.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Say this is a
discotheque, a night club.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: For example, you
have the dancers, the audience
of people who paid $100 a person
to come and dance in this club.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then
there are the dancers
that the club hires at $1,000
a night to actually dance
on the stage.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So they all
dance to the same music.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But the people
who paid $100 to dance, they're
having fun.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But the dancers
on the stage, they're working.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So the people below
stage are enjoying themselves.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if you
say extended club hours
by 30 minutes--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --the people
below stage, they love it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: The dancers on
the stage, they want overtime.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Why
such phenomenon?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: They're doing
the same exact things.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So why is it
that people below stage
are having fun?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And why is it
that the dancers on the stage
are working?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So the only
difference is money.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if
you pay, you have fun.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: If you take
money, then you're working.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So you're
all getting paid, right?
[LAUGHTER]
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So that's
why you're working.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
I'm not getting paid.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: I actually
have fun every single day.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's
how your mind operates.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So being
free from labor--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
being free from labor
is not a matter of you getting
paid a lot for a short time.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It's for you
to enjoy, or make fun,
out of your labor.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
how do you do that?
How do you transform
labor into fun?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That
means that you have
to become the agent
of your own actions.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So when
you pay money to dance,
the money is not the purpose.
You having fun is the purpose.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But if
you get paid to dance,
then dancing is not the purpose.
The money is the purpose.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So you
are actually selling
your professional dancing
abilities for money.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then you become
enslaved to that transaction.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's
why it's tough.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if you
look at those principles
that move our minds--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --then you are
able to diagnose at what
areas and what times
you feel happy.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: We
usually think that we
feel we are pleased
when we receive help--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --but
that's not so.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
that actually
is a path to enslaving yourself.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I
encourage you to examine
how your mind operates--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --so
that you can actually
bring more enjoyment
or fun to your work.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And to
your life, as well.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It's not
important whether you
die today or the next day.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because you need
to be happy today in order
to make your next
life happy, as well.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So no one can
prove that the next life exists
or not, of course.
MALE SPEAKER: If it exists,
you'll speak English.
[LAUGHTER]
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Do you have
any follow up questions?
MALE SPEAKER: Sunim,
that's a beautiful answer.
Oh by the way, I
do have an answer
for that question, what
is the meaning of life.
The meaning of life is not.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: Next question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I agree many of our sufferings
are really due to our mind.
But this year seems-- this
year has been especially
complicated or hard
to swallow for me.
I mean, early this year starting
with the Ukraine crisis,
and then the conflicts
in the Middle East.
We have this Ebola
outbreak and whatnot.
I feel as if the
entire universe is
kind of inching towards
the end, or so to speak.
And we're closing to the
autumn of the universe.
What's going on this year?
Is this thing going to continue?
What's your opinion?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So these
problems always exist.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: From
a long time ago.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And they
will always exist.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So the
world is not so complex.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So the
world becomes complex
if you lack the capacity
to understand it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: The karmas by
which you understand the world--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --was
created a long time ago.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But the
world has changed.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But
we are still trying
to analyze the world through
that karmic paradigm.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why
it's very, very difficult
for us to analyze
it, understand it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why
it makes it complex.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So the
mistake I make--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --think that
the world itself is complex.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So that's
why you need a new lens
by which to analyze the world.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So Ebola,
it's not a huge deal.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: There's a lot
of fear involved in the US.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It is the
fear that's a huge deal.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
even ISIS, that's
the same kind of
reactionary methods
that a weak, actually
a weak state,
actually usually
expresses itself.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because if you're
actually strong and confident,
you don't engage in such terror.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It is a method
of expression usually reserved
for the weak who are enraged.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So how
do you deal with it?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: If
you actually speak
to the source of their anger,
it becomes easy to deal with it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But if you
try to suppress them--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --you might
be able to stop it--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --but
it will continue.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
throughout history,
you've seen that happening.
Unless you manage to kill
off every single one,
it'll continue.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But we
can't do that today.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because we
don't allow ourselves
to kill others who
are bystanders.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why
we need a new method
of dealing with such phenomena.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
when nation states
are in conflict
with each other--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --we can't
solve their problem
with the same method.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So we need a new
way to approach such problems,
but we are always attached
to methodologies of the past.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
from my perspective,
I think we lack an understanding
of the human psyche.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Why
they act that way.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It looks
ridiculous and horrible
from our perspective.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So we
need to try to explore
why they feel as if they have
to behave in such a manner.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So it's not
a huge problem, per se.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But it's a
problem that we need to solve.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then we need
to explore solutions.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if
the strong can't
compromise with the weak--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --then that is
called embracing the weak.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And it's
spoken in a positive manner.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But if the
weak have to compromise--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --then they
say the weak capitulate.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And that is
not a good sounding word.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why if
you force them to capitulate,
they'll look for the next
opportunity to rebel.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So that
kind of methodology
brings about a temporary lull,
but not a permanent peace.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why the
strong needs to do something.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
There's a question here.
AUDIENCE: I've heard that
in some Buddhist traditions,
women are treated differently.
For instance, I've heard that
in order to become a Buddha,
a woman must first be
reincarnated as a man.
What do you feel about this?
What is your opinion?
Do you agree?
Do you think this is antiquated?
I'm curious.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
there's a difference
between Buddhist
Dharma and Buddhism.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
MALE SPEAKER: Define dharma.
Dharma means teaching, right?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So when
I speak of dharma,
it speaks to the teaching of
the truth as spoken by Buddha.
When I say Buddhism, I speak
more of the cultural artifacts
that surround the Buddhism.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So when
Buddha was alive,
there was a great
discrimination based on gender,
as well as based on the caste.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But Buddha thought
that you can't discriminate
between humans based
on their caste.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So when a person
wanted to become a monk,
he received them
without restrictions.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So there were a
lot of members from the lowest
caste among his sanga, his
original community of monks.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And he
taught that there
are four types of
rivers in this world.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But they all become
one sea when they flow out.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So likewise,
there are four different castes
in this world.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But within my
teachings, there's only one.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And he allowed
for women to become a convert.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And there
was a great opposition
to that at that time.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
at that time,
women were not considered
fully human beings.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
at that time,
women were not considered
capable of becoming
holy human beings by themselves.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because they had
to be somebody's daughter when
they were young.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And they
had to be somebody's wife
when they were married.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And when
the husband died,
they had to remain
as somebody's mother.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So they were
always labeled in attachment
to some male.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But for a woman
to actually convert and enter
into the community--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --then you are
allowing them, in effect,
to own themselves.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
acknowledging that they
are one independent, self
sufficient human being.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And he allowed that
while he was alive in that era.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But
after 300, 400 years--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --that
practice disappeared.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
Buddhism was dyed
by the originals, India's
traditional ideologies.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So in the
original ideology of India,
there are five things that
women can never become.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: They can
never be a wise king.
She can never be a wise king--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --could
never be a Buddha--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --could
never be [INAUDIBLE].
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --cannot become
one of the kings of one
of the heavens--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --and
cannot become a Brahmin.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And so that
traditional Indian belief
system entered into Buddhism.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And according
to that tradition,
women cannot become a Buddha.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then they
said, therefor women
do not need to become a monk.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So just do a
good deeds in this lifetime--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --and
be reborn as a man.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And then try
to become a Buddha, then.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But that's
not Buddhist teachings.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But in the
historical evolution
of Buddhism as an institution,
that actually has taken root.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And it is part
of the Theravada tradition
of Buddhism, but it is not part
of Buddha's original teaching.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But
it is true that we
have to recognize that in
today, in our current reality,
there is discrimination
in Buddhism against women.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But
instead of labeling them
as Buddhism is
actually a lingering
artifact from a feudal
society that we lived in.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And it is Buddhism
that actually has accepted,
been corrupted by
that tradition.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
that discrimination,
we can say it is part of a
Buddhist cultural tradition,
but you can't say it is part
of Buddha's original Dharma
teaching.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Do you have
any follow up questions?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
That was amazing.
MALE SPEAKER: You
know the Dalai Lama
had a commentary
on that question?
The Dalai Lama said,
he said his next life,
he wants to be
reborn as a woman.
So maybe there's a
suggestion for you.
Maybe you can be
reborn as a woman, too.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So Buddha said
the difference between genders,
label such as men and women, is
an illusion, is seeing things.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It is just a
preconception that you hold.
AUDIENCE: I went to the trip
with [INAUDIBLE] over here
in 2008 to China and North
Korea, border of North Korea.
And climbing the
mountains of [INAUDIBLE]
was very informative
and very nice.
But the thing was that one
of the most memorable moments
is when looking at the
North Korean border,
all the trees were chopped off.
Every single trees.
There were no trees
in the mountains.
And also seeing aid from
China getting rejected
and coming back from the North
Korean border back to China.
And so my question is, that
was when Kim Jong Il was still
in dictatorship.
So is the treatment of
civilians much better
now that Kim Jong
Un is in state?
Or even reunification?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So we are
not able to discover
any concrete improvements
over the human rights
situation in North Korea.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And I
can't say that there
has been any
concrete improvement
in the lives of everyday people.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
say people do say
that's Pyungyang,
the city itself,
has become a little livelier.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
it's in a way so we
can see that the market
economy has expanded somewhat.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And the amount
of private ownership that
are recognized
has also expanded.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So even
the collective farm
has been divided.
Not to individuals, per
se, but to smaller units,
to family units.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And small firms
has been also transformed.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So there has been
a lot of changes on the line.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But in terms
of politics and military,
there has been no change.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So we
still see no evidence
that the quality of life
has improved for people.
AUDIENCE: In your first answer
that was a really beautiful,
you talked about the importance
of the how instead of the what.
And I was wondering as people
try to go down this path
and look more inwards,
how do you advise them
in terms of spending
their time inwards.
Maybe people come to you
for the monastic tradition.
How do you advise people
of sort of the career
or the worldly life versus
more of an inward life?
Do you have any advice?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if you
go out to the hill,
if you see rabbits and
squirrels, you see them living.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if human
beings are supposedly better
than the other
animals, then there's
no reason why we
shouldn't live better.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Have you ever
seen a rabbit suffering?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Have you ever
seen them commit suicide?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Have you ever seen
them turn jealous and envious?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: They just live.
INTERPRETER: But
at the same time,
I'm not saying that they live
very enjoyable lives as well.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I believe
that as human beings,
we should live at least
as well as animals.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So we don't have
to live super enjoyable lives.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But we should
not subject our lives
to one of suffering, either.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So suffering really
arises not out of some survival
need, but it comes
from our mind itself.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
the fact is that it
is possible to resolve the
source of your suffering
if you spend enough
effort to explore it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Of
course, institution
could be changed or
improved to help us do that.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
the needs of an animal
are survival needs, basic needs.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
if they're hungry,
when they eat their full,
then the need disappears.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But not
with human beings.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I think to be
able to eat when you're hungry,
I think that's one of
our basic human rights.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
as institutions, we
need to guarantee that right.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But to eat
better, richer food--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --to live
in a bigger house--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: There's
no end to that.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: I think those
kind of relative desires
you need to moderate.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So there
are two solutions.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: From a so social
infrastructure point of view--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --to
lessen the distance
between the rich and poor.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
a sense of poverty
is a relative term
compared to the rich.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But as
individuals, it's up to us
to be able to
moderate our desires.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: To let
go of your greed.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So this
conversation could really
last a long time, so I
just want to conclude
by saying that it is possible,
fully possible, for you to just
make a little effort to
examine yourself and alleviate
your source of suffering.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So as
employees of Google,
what is it that's
causing your suffering?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: You're
living in the richest
country in the world.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
you are employed
by the best company in the
richest country in the world.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
you are the object
of envy for the
rest of the world.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: If
you are suffering--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --then the rest of
us have no option but despair.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: What are
we supposed to do, then?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if we go on
the way we do now, then--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --we believe
that heaven is a good place.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: If you
actually get there.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
they are probably
suffering, as well, then.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why we need
to kind of examine ourselves.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So for you to
live a little happier lives--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --it's good
for you as individuals.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But it is also
very important for the rest
of humanity.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if you
could expand your heart
to help others a little bit--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --and
you will amplify
your sense of happiness.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And really
improve the lives
of others around the world.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: If you continue
just running straight ahead--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --you don't
know whether you're
running into a cliff.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
not sure if you're
suggesting that happiness
is sort of the state
that we should
ideally be seeking.
But if it is, I
think to the people
that I know who
are the happiest,
and they're actually the
people that are most selfish.
And I observe that they're
very happy because they spend--
you know, all of our time
and energy are limited.
And they spend that
time and energy
on their own goals and
their own interests,
and they don't
really help others.
And that doesn't seem to
be the ideal way of living.
The ideal way of
living seems to be
some sort of balance between
seeking your own happiness,
and also seeking
others' happiness.
On the other end
of the spectrum,
I see other people
who are very selfless
and help a lot of
people selflessly,
but actually because they're so
neglectful of their own needs,
they're unhappy.
So it seems like we need
some sort of balance, right?
How would you suggest striking
an appropriate balance
between addressing
other people's needs
and increasing other
people's happiness,
and our own happiness?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: For example, I'm
carrying this heavy burden.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: I look
down at the ground
because this thing I'm
carrying is too heavy.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I have no
idea what others are carrying,
how heavy their burdens are.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
even if I knew it--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --I have no
capacity to help them carry it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But for example,
if I let go of more burden--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --then I
can actually look around.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then I can
actually see other people
carrying their burdens, as well.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And then
now I have capacity
to help them if I wanted to.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's
why first, you
need to be happy
first and foremost.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But by saying
you need to be happy,
I'm not saying only
you need to be happy.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: First and
foremost, you need to be happy.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then,
you have that capacity
to help others be happy.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if you think
you're sacrificing for others--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --that's
not sustainable.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because we
have limits to our patience.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: At some point
in time, you will explode.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: However for
you to benefit selfishly
while causing loss to others,
that's not sustainable, either.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because then
the people who suffer loss,
they won't be still.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why
it's not sustainable.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But for a sense of
happiness to be sustainable--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --you have to
achieve a state in which it's
good for me and good for you.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So a temporary
state of happiness
is not real happiness.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It's enjoyment.
Perhaps pleasure.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But that enjoyment
needs to be sustainable.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And we can
define that as happiness.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: To achieve that
state, it has to be good for me
and good for you.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And that's the
beginning, starting gate.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: The starting gate
should be you should be happy
yourself.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And so even
when you help others,
you must be happy
yourself helping others.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So when
you love others,
it must cause
happiness within you.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if helping
others causes you suffering,
then it's not a good way.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
then you want
some kind of
compensation in return.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So in
that, you actually
cause a seed-- you
actually create enemies
by helping with a
sense of compensation.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So you
have to recognize
that helping others is actually
a way to make yourself happy.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So that, I don't
think, is self centeredness.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
I believe that trying
to create a happier
world, the first step
starts with your own happiness.
MALE SPEAKER: The happiest
people I've never met
are all people with no hair.
So there's an
inverse correlation
between hair and happiness.
[LAUGHTER]
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So for us to
shave our heads actually
signifies that we
are very simple.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because if you have
too much thoughts in your head,
then that automatically
results in a heavier heart.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
I'm just urging you
to be a little light
headed in your thoughts.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: OK,
maybe this gentlemen
and then if there's
still a question,
we can come back to you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
your great teachings today.
I'd like to ask the question
about like the ones related
to the question about
the world itself.
So you said in your
answer, you said
like we have a lot of
problems in the world,
but it has been like
that for a long time.
But if you look at the companies
around the Silicon Valley,
we see a lot of business like,
make the world a better place.
Stuff like that.
Do you think with this
technology and innovation,
are we getting to a
better place as a world?
I'd like to know your
opinions on the meanings
of this innovation and
technology in our lives.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I'm not sure.
INTERPRETER: If you use
technology for a good cause,
then it will become
a better world.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And if you
use it for a bad cause,
you'll create a worse world.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why
technology in itself
is not efficient to
create a better world.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
we need people who
are willing to use
the technologies
to the betterment of the world.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because a better
weapon kills more people.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So a sharper knife
can be used very effectively
for other things,
but it could also
be used as a better weapon.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So it's not a
problem of the technology,
for example, a
sharper knife itself.
It's a problem of who wields it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because right
now, all you are focused on
is creating a
sharper, better knife.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So you
might think that it's
up to the people, whoever they
are, to use it to their end.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
I don't think so.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I think
it's part of your job
to prepare people to be able to
use your technology to better
ends.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because you need
to actually set the example,
exemplify how you could use
your technology to better ends
so that people can
follow your lead.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because if
you use your technology
for enrichment of
individuals, or in bad ways,
then people will follow
those examples, as well.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I'm here
today partially related
to that issue.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That you
yourself need to be happy.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
to encourage you
to take an interest in
how your technology can
be used in good ways.
MALE SPEAKER: Any questions?
OK, back to the lady.
AUDIENCE: Let's say,
OK, I have a loved one
and there was a
misunderstanding.
And there have been
many, many years where
I've tried to clear up
the misunderstanding
and it just hasn't cleared up.
So it's been difficult for me.
And the question is, until
when do I keep on trying.
Or do I just, for my own
emotional lightness of being,
just sever the
relationship and move on?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So why do you
think it's a misunderstanding?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It's
a misunderstanding
from your perspective.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Maybe
from his perspective,
it's not a misunderstanding.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So you need
to examine that first.
AUDIENCE: Well, I guess
to be more open and honest
about this-- so I
tried to explain
as clear as possible
my true intention
and the loved one is saying
that that's not true.
So refuses to accept
what I'm saying.
And then I don't
know where to go.
Because I feel like I've
been fully honest and open,
but the loved one
will not believe me.
And accuses a
different intention.
I don't know where to go.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So the
key to the situation
is the fact that
you believe that he
has a misunderstanding
that you want
to continue the relationship.
AUDIENCE: Well I guess it's
a loved one, it's a relative,
and so I'd like to keep the
relationship going and strong.
But again, I'm trying to
be honest with how I feel
and my intentions, but the loved
one says that that's not true.
So keeps on saying,
suggesting that I'm lying
or misrepresenting how I really
feel, when I'm being honest.
So that's my challenge.
Do I keep on trying to
persuade with the truth which
that person won't
accept, or do I
somehow just try and
forget the person
and leave and just kind
of sever the relationship
and try and forget
that person completely?
But it's difficult for
me, because that person
is obviously a loved
one and I would
like to improve the relationship
instead of run away.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I
do understand you
wanting to improve
the relationship,
but you have to face the
fact that it's not improving.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So you
can't really get
everything you
want in this life.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
you can try more--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --or you can stop.
INTERPRETER: So if
you stop now, you
feel maybe you didn't
try hard enough.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But
if you try harder,
it's not going to be
easy to resolve, either.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But instead
of looking to him,
look at yourself.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But ultimately,
the essence of the problem
is you don't want to be
criticized or misunderstood.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Let's say he
did have a misunderstanding.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then he was hurt
by that misunderstanding.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So, well,
let him insult you.
Let him curse at you.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
accept it willingly.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Instead
of criticizing him--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --allow him
to insult you even more.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if
you think that's going
to help him overcome his anger.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then go
ahead, insult me more.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So be
lighthearted in your approach.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then you
won't feel such impatience
at resolving this situation.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: If he
avoids you, then there's
nothing you can do.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But you have
no reason to avoid him.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
you're already
prepared to take whatever
he throws at you.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then you free
yourself from the result,
whether the situation
improves or not.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
you can't always
have people praising you.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because even
Buddha was criticized.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And Jesus was
misunderstood and crucified.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So even those
sages were criticized.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
people like us, it's
no big deal for us to be
insulted and criticized.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So be
willing to accept that.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then it's OK.
INTERPRETER: First and foremost,
you have to open yourself up.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Instead of
trying to resolve something--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --just understand
that he does have a scar.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And just encourage
him to criticize you even more.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And be
receptive to all that.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And if
you have that attitude,
then nothing is an issue.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: What do you think?
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
AUDIENCE: You said
that to be happy,
we have to remove
our greediness.
It sounds very simple,
but in practice it's
very difficult to
remove our greediness.
So can you suggest how can
we practice in our life
to remove our greediness?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: An
option is for you
to hold on to your
greediness and suffer.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But if
you suffer enough,
if the suffering is severe
enough, then you will let go.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: For example,
let's say this object is hot.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if I grab it--
INTERPRETER: --how do I react?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then I let go.
INTERPRETER: But if I'm
holding on to this hot object--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --and I say I'm
suffering because this is hot,
this is hot.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And so
I say, let it go.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then he says--
INTERPRETER: --give
me a way to let it go.
Teach me a methodology
to let it go.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So is it because
of a lack of methodology
that you don't let go?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: No.
INTERPRETER: It's because
your greed is on holding it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if you
do want to hold onto it--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --then
burn yourself.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But if you
don't want to burn yourself--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --just let go.
INTERPRETER: So it's not
an issue of methodology.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
that's what we teach.
If you know that
it's hot, let it go.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And just let it go.
INTERPRETER: So basically it
means in Chinese characters,
just let it go.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then people
still keep asking questions.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Please teach
me a way to let it go.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So that's
why as a last option,
I tell them then throw
it to your left hand.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
so they yell at me,
why didn't you teach me sooner?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because I just
solved how hot it was--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --and then I
still keep holding on to it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So it
looks like a solution.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then eventually
your left hand gets hot.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then he
keeps complaining,
my left hand is hot.
So I said, put it on your thigh.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So he said wow,
that's a great solution.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
neither of my hands are hot.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: I still
hold on to the bottle.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But then again,
your knees become hot.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So after
five such steps--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: If you
finally let it go--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --is
that a good way?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: These
were nonessential ways,
useless ways.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
that's why you have
to go to the core
of the problem.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
it's not the matter
of not knowing the
right methodology.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: You just
don't want to let it go.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
you say you suffer,
but you don't want to let it go.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
then you have to be
able to deal with the suffering.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Why do we live?
INTERPRETER: Do we
live to suffer, though?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: If that's not it--
INTERPRETER: --then
you have to let it go.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I do understand
how difficult this is.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: To a smoker--
INTERPRETER: --how does
a smoker quit smoking?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
my answer is easy.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Stop smoking.
INTERPRETER: So
everybody understands it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But
there's one who doesn't.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: The smoker
does not understand it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: He says,
how can I stop smoking?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
by that question,
he's actually implying that
he wants to continue smoking.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: His
consciousness is telling him
that he should stop smoking.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But
his subconsciousness
wants to continue smoking.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So it's a habit.
INTERPRETER: Habits are
difficult to get rid of.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So you have to
choose two options, then.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So provide
a strong anti stimulus.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: A
stimulus strong enough
to delve and reach down
into your subconscious.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: For
example, say you
put some kind of
electronics on your filter.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So it
gives you shock--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --every time you
smoke, you put it to your lips.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It's strong
enough for you to faint.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: If you repeat
this several times--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --then it
is your subconscious
that develops a fear,
an aversion to smoking.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So there's
a way to do that
by using that kind of
strong anti stimulus.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: For example, if
you want to control your anger
management, it's very difficult.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: If you really,
really want to fix it--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --every
time you become angry--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --so take some car
batteries and shock yourself.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: You
do it just 5 times.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then
the next time you
feel yourself getting
angry, your body
will react and start shaking.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But is there
really a need for you
to go that far to fix a habit?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why
you end up not fixing it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But the
second solution is--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --to
actually do this
over a long time, consistently.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
whatever choice you
make, whatever
decision you make,
consciously you have to
train yourself to carry it
on consistently over
a long period of time.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Until
that state of conscious
affects your subconscious.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if you
repeat something long enough,
it becomes a habit.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: If something
becomes a habit,
it means you have made it into
part of your subconscious.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: The same thing
as the law of physics.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So there are
properties to objects.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So we all know
about the law of inertia.
Anything that's in movement
want to continue moving.
Anything that stops wants
to continue stopping.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: We all
know this, right?
In physics?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: For example,
this is moving towards me.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And I
have to stop this.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: There
are only two ways.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Stop it with
a strong force against it--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --then it'll stop
after pushing a little bit.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But
if you want to use
small strength,
force, to stop it--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --then it'll
take a while before it stops.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So there
are only two ways.
To use a strong force to stop
in short time, or smaller
force to stop over a
long period of time.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But we don't
want to use a strong force.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And we
are not consistent.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's
why we allow our karma
to self amplify itself
over and over again.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why you
don't see any transformation.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And say because you
don't see the transformation,
you say this is unfixable.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: This is something
that I was born with.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why
in Chinese tradition,
you have the stars.
By the date and time you're born
with, your fortune is fixed.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: In
India, your destiny
is fixed by what you did
in your previous lifetime.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And in
Western theistic tradition,
it's God who preordained
your destiny.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
change is so difficult,
they're saying that
change does not happen.
It's preordained.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: By that's not so.
Nothing is unchanging.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
a karma is something
that has been manufactured.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So as
such, it does change.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But to
change it, however--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --it is difficult.
INTERPRETER: Because it
has been manufactured
over a long period of time.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: The
earlier it was formed,
the less change it experiences.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So either do
it forcefully, or do it
over a long period of time.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: By
doing so, anybody
can actually affect change.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But we
never actually even try.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: We
just want change.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But we don't put
the requisite effort behind.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Even if we
actually spend a little effort--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --we give up and
say, eh, it's not worth it.
Didn't happen.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So do it forcefully
over a long period of time.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then you can
change, no matter who you are.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So intellectually
understanding this concept,
intellectually it is an
activity of the consciousness.
So it doesn't really affect
change fundamentally.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But if
your heart, for example,
if your heart is moved over
a story that you hear--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --then
that makes it easier
for you to change
your behaviors.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: For your
heart to have moved,
that means you have
affected your subconscious.
MALE SPEAKER: Sunim, in closing,
if we remember only one thing
from today, what do you
want us to remember?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Try to
suppress something.
Try to be patient
against something.
It's not a good thing.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: For example,
if you become angry,
you express your anger.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then the target
of your anger becomes stressed.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And that anger
comes right back at you.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then that
amplifies your anger.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So you're
actually mutually amplifying.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It is
a foolish option.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's
why as a second option,
we tell people to
suppress your anger.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So at least you
don't transfer your anger
to the other person.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So you stop it
from amplifying the situation.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So from
that sense, that's
a good method from the outside.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And you get
praised for being patient.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But then you
create stress for yourself.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So a lot of
us experience that state.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So
that, ultimately,
is not really good for you.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So we said, don't
even suppress your anger.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then people
ask, then what can I do?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: You tell
me not to get angry--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --then
don't even suppress it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then what to do?
INTERPRETER: So it
might sound that way.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But if you
look at it a little deeper--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --say you feel
this anger rising within you.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So then you
have only two options.
To express that anger, or
to suppress that anger.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But if you go back
to the root of that anger--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --you
have to observe
the anger originating
within you.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if that
anger never rises--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --then you
don't have to suppress it,
nor express it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's
why we ask people
to go deeper into the roots.
Ask yourself, why
do I get angry?
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So you
need to delve deeper--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --and become a
person who is not angered.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But
we allow ourself
to sink into a
state of ignorance.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because anger
rises from the subconscious
within us.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And our
conscious does not always
catch it in time.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's
why we teach people
for your conscious to
be awake at all times.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But
sometimes it escapes us.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So we tell
people to catch your anger,
be aware of your anger.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if you can
catch your anger and observe it,
it doesn't amplify.
It actually reduces in
volume and disappears.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So you're not
trying to suppress it, per se.
You're trying to
become aware of it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: To be awake to it.
INTERPRETER: So you don't
create stress that way.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But say
you lost that moment.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Say that you
actually expressed your anger.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then we
usually make an excuse
that it's your fault
that I'm angry.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: At that moment,
you have to look at yourself.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: You say,
I lost that moment.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And you have
to kind of review yourself.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then that
anger is not amplified.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
that allows your life
to become much more comfortable.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So what I'm
not try to suppress stress.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because
you need to resolve it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So I think
exploding in anger
is not a resolution.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why
you have to maintain
a constant state
of awakefulness.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And for
that, to reach that state,
you need practice.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: That's why
meditation is a good practice.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: The
first step is for you
to recognize, be
awake to your breath.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And try to
maintain a state of tranquility
on your mind.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So of
course it's easier
to maintain that when
you're sitting down.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But it's also
difficult to maintain it
while you're actually
encountering people.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: But just because
you fail, it's not a bad thing.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Because it allows
you to explore why you failed.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And then take
that back to your practice.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then experiment
with it in real life.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Then go
back and practice again.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So if you
put it in that effort--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --where nothing is
going to completely go away--
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: --but
perhaps 80% of it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: It's very easy to
arrive at a much better state.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: The sense
you are able to create
much happier lives
for yourselves.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: Much more
comfortable lives,
tranquil lives.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And your
relationship with others
will improve.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And from that
space of peace and comfort,
you can be much more creative.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: So the final
words I'd like to say to you
and ask you to take
back as a take away is,
instead of trying to
suppress anything,
try to be awake to it.
Mindful of it.
POMNYUN SUNIM: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
INTERPRETER: And
I wish all of you
great happiness in your lives.
MALE SPEAKER: My friends, the
amazing master Pomnyun Sunim.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]